indem ich ihn komplett selbst schreibe
den text das hilft sehr ich bin ein ganz
schlechter text lernen wenn es um texte
von anderen geht hatte ich schon immer
riesen schwierigkeiten aber ich lerne
wahnsinnig schnell wenn ich selber
schreibe wenn ich wenn es meine eigenen
gedanken sind die ich da formuliere oder
wenn es meine eigenen gedanken sind die
häufig auch im programm selbst erst
entstehen und die ich dann wieder ein
flechte das hilft sehr und eigentlich
ist das für mich dass das das ganze
geheimnis und daneben natürlich eine
ungeheure konzentration die aber durch
die bühnensituation auch entsteht